over at least my mindset changes when I
come here I was reading this message
Caspar wrote and it says here then I
imagine that this is happening actually
here and it was very troubling to me so
I will some of you who have heard this
talk at some version of it I hope you
will still find it interesting it's
about two ideas one is round elimination
which is a very simple way to probe
lower bounds conceptual way and another
is a triangular discrimination which is
a measure of distance which is useful
for performing round elimination so the
two parts of the talk these two parts
we will start with ground elimination
then we will do discuss this distance
and then the only thing that we actually
prove is some example I will show some
example that is meaningful I see so the
round elimination is 4 this is a very
simplistic model or may be to actually
make it into a module you need to say
more things but so there is some
computational process and it operates in
rounds and in every round it says
something so in round I it says mi and I
depends on the input X and what happened
before and the last message mro the last
thing that happened should tell you
something about X the input X and the
type of thing we would like to show is
that our should be large that this to
achieve its goal the computation must
operate in many rounds this is the type
of problem we question you want to
answer okay so yeah to make this
specific you need to say more things
even you need to put some restrictions
may be on the model
so the way around elimination suggests
to operate in something like this we
want to find something that is hard for
our rounds I call it X R is the input
for the are round problem and FL is the
type of thing we want to compute and the
way we do this is we construct them in
some way so that if we have this and we
have some solution for this problem in
our rounds then this gives us a solution
for some other problems that we already
constructed 4-1 rounds so this is the
logical structure of the proof we want
to find something that is hard for our
rounds we construct it in a specific way
that allows us to from the solution for
something that is from for excel and F
we get a solution for X R minus 1 and F
R minus 1 this we need to do for the
specific model we are interested in and
then after we like we do this for our x
we reach X 0 and F 0 which are
supposedly solved without any rounds of
anything and this would should be
impossible because there are somehow
non-trivial for the model we have
interested so this is the round
elimination idea and typically what
happens in this type of procedure is
that there is some error in the
computation and it keeps growing
throughout the application of this idea
so in the beginning it is 1/10 then it
becomes 1/3 and then it becomes
yeah so they hopefully the whole
argument we we find is that the arrow
here is still somehow - meaning somehow
meaningful the specific model in which
this idea was first suggested I think
this communication complexity and the
two parties setting so here is what four
people I listed before suggested to do
so in this model there are two players
Alice and Bob Alice gets an input X Bob
gets an input Y and then they talk Alice
says something a message that depends on
X then Bob says something a message that
depends on Y and on M 1 and so forth
until they communicate the left message
so this is the model and I guess you
know it so the way the round elimination
should go like this at level 0 we find
some something that is hard F so f is
somehow it function for when there is no
communication this is pretty easy to
find then for one round protocols what
we should do we should do placate
Alice's input some large number of times
n times and give all of these and things
to Alice Bob will get some part of X
let's say the so we choose some J this
is this which choose Sanjay give Bob
everything before J and some Y and the
goal of Alice and Bob in the level 1
thing is to compute F of XJ and why so
this should be harder than this in the
sense that Alice needs to say something
about XJ but she does not know what J is
so communication is sort of split evenly
between these things and this therefore
should be harder this is the intuition
and you can make this form and in some
level one there is one round of
communication and then you can make this
concrete in many models not just
communication complexity okay so this is
the round elimination idea and you can
prove lower bounds on communication
complexity using this and I want to do
to suggest some other perspective on the
same thing don't eliminate rounds this
is pretty this will lead to losses in
the argument so here is a different
perspective on the same instead of
eliminating rounds do something slightly
different show that when u unic a tit
for around then you some messages m were
sent in these around some data was
collected in these AI rounds and look on
the distribution of the variable that
comes from the r- i construction without
any knowledge of anything this is this
distribution and compare it to the
distribution
on this thing when these messages were
sent in these rounds so we compared a
distribution well nothing happened to a
computer to a distribution where the
whole thing operated for AI rounds and
try to argue that it does it in every
step the distance between what we
learned and what we so this captures
somehow what we learned in these AI
rounds what we learned about this part
of the inputs so try to argue that in
every single round this does not
increase by more than epsilon for some
Epsilon
okay so here there is no elimination of
nothing we just look on the protocol and
try to say the distribution of this or
the distribution of the some part of the
input is unaffected by the protocol it's
basically the same this is very close to
this this is the some distribution that
is hard that you got so the distribution
for our rounds is constructed in some
gradual manner and this is the
distribution for the rest of the thing
okay it's confusing
yeah we communicated the first around
there are are - arounds left the left
and this should be this is the input to
the list okay so the reason I think this
is a better system than eliminating
round is that here we can write whatever
distance we want when we eliminate
routes we basically must use statistical
distance this is part of the the
mechanism the rationale and not sure how
to say but here we can write whatever we
want and there are many distances and
some of them are better than statistical
distance so this is the next thing we
want to talk about is what type of
distances we can use and maybe one
specific distance which is called
angular discrimination so this is it
about round elimination not a lot of so
event what eventually it should be if
all of this thing actually you can prove
such a lemma then we will have the
distribution on X on so Y on X 0 and the
distribution of X 0 condition on the
whole protocol if this number is small
then it it means that X 0 condition on
the whole messages is distributed
exactly as if nothing has happened so
this is shows that the product the
protocol does not achieve its goal but
it's a sort of the goal is actually if
they almost irrelevant you
you just say the protocol did nothing it
said nothing about this part of the
input
maybe it's the rest of the input is not
the answer we construct the thing so
that x0 is where the answer we are
interested in is yes so this is round
elimination and now I want to talk about
distances so there are many ways to
measure distances and maybe the very big
family of distances are called
divergences so these are the people
related to this definition so it's all
fun so this is a distance it's not a
metric but it's a virgin's between two
distributions there is some distribution
P and some distribution Q and we want to
define some number that depends on P and
Q that is somehow related to their
distance so here is one way to do it we
choose any function any convex function
f we want and and we insist that at the
point the one variable convex nothing
obstruct we insist that at the point one
it evaluates to zero then we get this
quantity
No and so okay then the next slide maybe
we help to and this will help you to
understand so okay this is a some
formula not so maybe interesting oh no
it's hard to tell but basically all the
notions we I know of of this form and
they come with the this definition comes
with some nice properties so maybe first
some examples so here there is a list of
the graph of three functions with the
function 1 minus X with absolute value
there is the function X log X and in the
there is this function X minus 1 squared
over X plus 1 this is this function you
can draw many other functions right so
this function the the first one is l1
distance with this function the X log X
function is diverted a KL divergence
which is the formation field so maybe it
helps to see it's not log log is
actually not convex but X log X is so
it's X log X this is the right way to
write it which is a strange it's like
writing
so we write the KL divergence it should
be it should be
this is how we typically write this but
the way it is written here is like this
thing if you treat division by zero
correctly but somehow in this version it
is much easier to understand it so it
will show something so strange so and
basically everything you can put into
this and do we find some F every metric
you use so the properties it come this
definition comes with three simple
properties one it's a non-negative
number this is pretty good for a
distance second because F is convex this
function is convex in the abstract this
is just some point in some space and
it's convex in this input and the last
property that holds also by convexity is
what is called the data processing
property if there were a to distribution
over the same space x and y and then we
applied g some function on this space so
we get G of X and G of Y the distance of
this is smaller than the distance of
this this we process the data the
distance can only shrink so for mutual
information this is called a data
processing maybe it's more well known
but this is always true in this
generality so this makes it a nice
family or distribution and there are
more of things that people know how to
make no properties
we have okay
now for when we actually try to prove
lower bounds it's very important to
switch between different distances at
the right time so one way to do this
very values for the spin scale
inequality which relates l1 distance to
divert to KL divergence this is a very
useful tool in equality now we are in so
so Delta I introduced it here it's the
thing you get when you use this function
[Music]
so there is some another thing some
other object we which has the word
triangular in it and this notion
captures the unit distance between these
triangular things there is some reason
so now I want to tell you about this
triangle discrimination so it is almost
l1 in the sense that it is smaller than
l1 and not much larger than n1 is in
Pinsker and here I wrote Delta again in
a more way it's like l2 but we divide by
the sum like not l2 l2 squared and the
last thing which is most important to us
is that when you have to try to do
Pinsker with this there is no square
root so this is the the most important
property for us so there is an analog of
Pinsker but there is no square root all
of these pins curve and this this is a
two variate problem in calculus with two
variables this is what it reduces to the
minute we go to l1 we lost so the the
point I want to make is that we should
keep this throughout
and maybe another property so I will
show you I will will finish I will not
say everything I planned so another
important property of a object is to
understand its operational meaning what
can we do with this so specifically in
this context what we we have like we are
interested in statistics so what are the
type of tests we are allowed to use to
test our statistical hypothesis so l1
correspond to tests whose L infinity is
bounded by 1 so when we measure distance
in l1 it corresponds to the maximum
difference between the answer for a test
with P and an answer for a test with Q
where this test is bounded by 1 point
wise so this is l1 this Delta this
tranquil discrimination is also the
maximum distance between the ends of two
tests there is a square here but the
tests are no longer bounded point wise
but only in variance just the sort of
the variance of the test is bounded so
this is the most much more loose
condition this is a point wise thing
this is the average field so Delta can
be applied more generally with more
tests it is meaningful so this is a
triangle discrimination and now I just
want to show you the example so it was
used in several works unexpectedly I
would say in group theory
so here is the example that drives all
of this information theory poof's there
is some random variable on the cube with
very very high entropy and the way we
write it this language the distance of
the distribution of weeks from uniform
is K the KL divergence
so then what KL divergence allows us to
do which is amazing is to do
subadditivity what does it mean it means
that if we choose a random coordinate
and look on the ice coordinate of weeks
it will be close to a uniform bit and
the distance is divided by n this is the
property of divergence that makes it
most useful for us and then if you use
Pinsker we can deduce that the random
coordinate is almost uniform with this
loss when you we go to l1 we lost this
factor and now I want to suggest the the
type this type of question is useful to
understand when we actually try to make
these arguments instead of choosing a
completely random coordinate we choose
some coordinate J which is it's not
completely uniform but it is close to
uniform in divergence so we perturb it
slightly the distribution now epsilon is
small it's not K it's actually small
difference between this is the
distribution of I which is uniform on
the numbers between 1 & M and this is
some distribution on the numbers 1 to n
that is close to it
now we can ask ourselves is now we
choose some other random index with
another distribution is it well that
this is close to uniform so the first
answer is yes but it is a red yes it's
not so good if we use pin scale then we
get that the distance is this distance
square root plus the previous thing so
this is a pimp's curve and this is
single now the point is that when we do
Delta there is no square roots
you just get this so you can perform the
whole argument and never write a square
root in the process which is a pretty
good thing so if you do this you can
actually improve parameters in many
cases so this is the example and then
there is a proof of this example it's
not so interesting and this is the
summary so the way at least I think
about it we want to analyze some
expectation and the distribution is too
complicated for us we have no way to do
this what do we do we replace P by some
other distribution Q which is very
simple for some reason but it is close
to pain in terms of this Delta if we are
able to do this and the variances of G
are controlled then we are good we did
we achieved our goal
so this is a I'm now I'm quick because
we don't have much time I guess I'm
overtime anyhow yeah yeah I guess I'm
very slow so just a summary there is
this idea of analyzing proving lower
bounds on the round complexity and one
way to do it is using round elimination
it's a pretty good way then there is a
very vast collection of distances that
we can use and maybe we should find some
other out there that are useful and
specifically this measure helps to
remove the square root so it makes all
of the arguments quantitatively better I
would say they're simpler but in the
sense that
so there are simpler adjust in the sense
that once you introduce this type of
argument there is no conditioning on and
just analyze some expectation and just
be - so in this sense it is simpler but
you can do the same with l1 as well and
then you will just write square roots
sometimes so it doesn't in this sense it
doesn't simplify this was the interest
my intention when I said this high level
thing and so I will just oh maybe it's a
maybe I will write instead of yeah we
just want to try to understand
we want to understand the average this
is something we want to understand the
average of G the expectation of G now
this is hard to out for us then we work
we write it just write this and now when
we write this automatically Delta comes
into the picture sort of Delta allows to
treat such a such an expression so Delta
will take care of this and then we just
need to so in this type of operation
happens it's a natural thing to do
sometimes
so in exact for example
when not so it will be clear when there
is some underlying martingale then q can
be the next step in the martingale and
then you just this is a natural thing to
do so q it defined somehow from P by an
extra step or one less step and then
this is related to some property of the
group of some other so so this is the
you just analytically replaced P by Q in
this very simple way the motivation for
this is different I don't have one
answer but once we write this Delta is
here it comes automatically we do one
push VARs and you see Delta
think of you again
[Applause]